[Musique]
je suis star wars depuis 1977
et quand j'ai vu le premier épisode donc
j'étais au collège et aujourd'hui je
vois la fin de cette saga c'est
peut-être il fallait que l'histoire se
termine et elle se termine de façon
magnifique
quelle est leur aide et rei il y avait
beaucoup d'attentes sur ce qu'allait
faire ré en terme de est-ce qu'elle va
basculer du côté obscur ou pas moi j'ai
bien aimé la manière dont l'intrigué tu
es mené le fender niveau mise en scène
c'est au top
évolution des personnages c'est au top
music au top aussi donc si on n'a pas
aimé le 8
on peut quand même donner sa chance aux
neuf vaut mieux avoir aimé le set et
avoir vu le set au 6 mai faune y aller
voir regretterez pas
[Musique]